that's what's interesting about as an
Asian I can say this okay about Asian
culture is that very smart yes but not a
lot of creativity and that's why even
today you see throughout also a lot of
history right
Chinese invented gunpowder weren't using
it practically yeah who started using it
in a room because you had to think
outside the box I've never seen this
before right and there's a very Asian
culture of you know sort of this
submissive hey follow the strict line
you know do this do that but not a lot
of creativity and I think you see this
even in China for school if you want to
come to American school or whatever like
they'll just train your whole life to
take the S18 you probably get a perfect
score but then what after that what
happens when you have to be say an
engineer and you have to actually think
creatively right and it's something
lacking in a lot of Asian culture I love
that for a thousand years they have
gunpowder these Southeast Asians Chinese
are like look at the stuff we made look
what happens when you light it like whoa
and then Europeans like
I could kill a lot of people with that